j'avais écrit une tribune dans
libération appelant à voter manuel
macron pour le au deuxième tour
honnêtement parfois je relis cette
tribune et j'ai mal au ventre je dirige
les bras m'en tombent
rien de ce que j'avais rien de ce que
j'appelais de mes voeux ni la défense de
la république ni la défense de la
démocratie
nahla lieux et les domaines des tweets
utilisait si marine le pen arrive au
pouvoir s'est aucunement comparable
parce qu'elle elle elle sera xénophobe
d'assumer et force est de constater que
c'est plutôt macron aujourd'hui kim a
une belle petite politique xénophobe
comme disent aurélien kong le disque
quand j'entends certains ce que certains
députés ont dit de l'appeler quand
marche sur les gilet jaune en disant
qu'ils étaient manipulés par moscou et
par poutine
je me demande qui est en plus triste
c'est marine le pen c'est emmanuel
macron nostalgiques de grands noms de
notre histoire dont nous avons honte et
qui ne devrait une force et qui a
demandé par pourrait donner réparation
moi je pensais que ça s'était marine le
pen en fait la une si elle prenait le
pouvoir qu'elle est r ça quand je vois
ce que fait
macron qui veut célébrer pétain en fait
je veux dire que j'ai tout faux dans la
tribune que j'avais rédigé
donc quand je t'entends dire je
comparais de thomas piketty
peut-être que thomas piketty aussi se
dit bon match lui même si je me suis
trompé on a droit de se tromper on a le
droit de d'imaginer quelque chose à un
instant t
et puis 3 4 en cinq ans après voir voir
qu'on a les phares et non ce que je veux
ce que je veux dire aussi c'est hulk va
falloir que l'on se remette
collectivement mais ça ça marche pour
emmanuel macron et pour la gauche à
faire de la politique à ce qu'on fait
c'est ça le problème à mon avis ces sacs
dont manque le débat public aujourd'hui
c'est de faire de la politique
emmanuel macron ils veulent des petites
idées n'était pas si mauvaise que ça le
grand débat national ce n'était pas une
si mauvaise idée que ça la convention
pour le climat s'était pas non plus une
si mauvaise idée que ça je sais c'était
des occasions en fait de vraiment faire
de la politique
faire un débat national est affecté
était président était prêt dès vraie
confrontation du vrai conflit politique
le seul point c'est qu'il a tout pris a
touché à la poubelle c'est le constat
est absolument
cru mais si on arrive aujourd'hui en
france on a encore un an pour faire ça à
recréer cette envie collective en france
2 politique je pense qu'on peut réussir
à éviter le duo macro locale
[Musique]